fait
par un dimanche matin ensoleillé hugo
pour vous hein ça va au parc avec sa
femme et sa fille mais la balade en
traîneau ne se termine pas comme prévu
le temps de faire un tour de parcs
d'arrêter jouer un petit peu glissé on
revient et alors qu'on est encore dans
le sentier donc juste là on est à
quelques secondes de revenir à la
voiture d'un sous nos yeux notre servi
notre véhicule s'en va tout
tranquillement nous on avait déjà eu une
tentative de vol sur ce véhicule en
avril l'année passée la honda cr v est
le véhicule le plus volés au québec
selon le palmarès 2021 suivent ensuite
les camionnettes ford de la série f des
lexus enix lambda civique et la toyota
highlander le véhicule est victime de
son succès plus je le vis que les bars
du mais plus il est en demande pourquoi
des pièces vont être vendus dans un
autre pays alors les voitures et les bus
les camions ont achevé les plus
populaires sont cherchons le plus volé
les concessionnaires automobiles ne sont
pas à l'abri
gravel honda est victime de vol dans son
propre stationnement ou encore lorsque
ces véhicules sont prêtés en courtoisie
ce qui fait bondir les primes
d'assurance on a une augmentation de
300% la prime au triple saut sera pas du
tout celles qui ont monté d'à peu près
1000 % les voleurs sont de plus en plus
actifs de 2015 à 2020 au dénombrait
moins de 5000 vols de voitures chaque
année à montréal mais l'an dernier selon
bret grimper à plus de 6500 depuis que
le déconfinement est en place
effectivement il ya 7 à la hausse et une
hausse rapide que ce soit au québec -
l'ontario la cause de la pandémie
adhérentes et pierre salons les voitures
sont beaucoup beaucoup en banque les
stratagèmes des valeurs évoluent au gré
de la technologie ils sont capables de
déjouer les clés intelligentes qui
permettent de démarrer un véhicule en
appuyant sur un bouton à condition de
les avoir sur soi le tour est joué en
moins d'une minute c'est malheureusement
très facile ça
généralement 2 deux malfaiteurs qui se
place près de la porte d'entrée avec un
appareil qui va capter le signal de la
clé intelligente qu'on a laissé le près
de la porte par exemple et une autre
personne qui est près de la voiture avec
un autre appareil et ces deux appareils
vont se parler le signale la clé
intelligente arrive donc dans l'appareil
du malfaiteur qui est à côté de l'auto
de déverrouiller la porte hier s'asseoir
dans le véhicule démarrer le moteur est
parti mais hugo bourgoin lui a été
victime d'un autre stratagème beaucoup
plus répandue son véhicule a été
retrouvé par un huissier le lendemain du
vol dans un stationnement situé à 1 km
du parc plus trouvé ce louche qui est un
cervidé stationnés dans le fond du
stationnement vais rentrer le numéro de
plaque puis à des bus et un véhicule
volé donc lui s'y installent il un sabot
de denver sur notre véhicule pour être
sûrs qu'ils bougent pas de la communique
avec le neuf en tant que policier m'a
appris ce qu'ils me disent et vinay mais
c'est sûr que vous pourrez pas partir
avec assurément un vote clé fonctionnera
plus pour ouvrir les portes pour faire
démarrer levé que la porte de sa honda
cr v a été forcée et selon toute
vraisemblance le voleur s'est ensuite
branché au port ob d2 c'est à dire à la
prise diagnostic situé sous le tableau
de bord on voyait insérer un petit
module électronique qui permet aux
malfaiteurs à ce moment là avec un
ordinateur un autre appareil d'aller
carrément dans l'ordinateur de commandes
du véhicule et créer une clé
intelligente donc c'est comme si on
repartait à zéro qu'on a signés nouvelle
qui est intelligente aux véhicules les
voleurs déplace ensuite les véhicules et
les laisse reposer une journée ou deux
au cas où un système de repérage
permettrait de les retrouver comme ils
ont fait avec la voiture d'hugo bourgoin
une technique pour éviter de se faire
pincer par la police six personnes est
venue lui tout un corner et la marque
dans le véhicule ils s'en vont la porter
ou recyclables s'il n'a pas été marqué a
volé ce qu'on appelle coupé chop chop
ses expressions dans leur garage ou
avoir est reparti directement aux
parents mais dans un cas d'erreur puis
envoyés à l'extérieur
selon lui c'est l'oeuvre de réseaux
criminels qui utilisent le port de
montréal pour mener leurs activités on
veut trouver les véhicules du québec à
beyrouth au liban on avait eu avec des
plaques volées en russie en sierra leone
au nigeria le fabricant tout ce qu'ils
trouvent à nous dire c'est fait vous
installer un système de repérage donc si
ce qu'on a fait finalement mais on
comprendra besta des coups de centaines
de dollars supplémentaires chez gravel
honda on a décidé de prendre le taureau
par les cornes sans attendre le
manufacturier on a un système chez nous
qu'on fait mais pour le moment il
confine à la longueur pour nous mais que
si - vraiment voir la fed à partir avec
le véhicule avec une fausse clic
automatiquement le système d'aram
déclenché le vote du report pur pitcho
pour se prémunir contre les vols on peut
placer sa clé intelligente dans une
boîte en métal quand on est à la maison
ça bloque les ondes et s'empêche donc
les voleurs de 10 amplifié on peut aussi
faire installer un protecteur daube et d
un petit boîtier en métal qui protègent
la prise de diagnostic il ya aussi le
système de repérage et la bonne vieille
barre antivol qui permet de verrouiller
le volant au fait plusieurs couches de
sécurité puis un renard soient
découragés et il reste de choisir un
autre véhicule